speaking of despicable I want to talk
about SeaWorld SeaWorld has announced
earlier today that it's going to end its
killer whale breeding program and take
what they're calling a new direction
because of changing social attitudes now
when they say social attitudes yeah
people are not that thrilled with the
horrible imprisonment and unethical
treatment of social animals like orca
whales and the pressure started to build
against SeaWorld years ago you remember
the documentary blackfish Lewis
extraordinary documentary devastating
documentary and difficult documentary to
watch which makes the very clear case
that when you put these whales in
captivity you make them violent you make
them neurotic you decrease their
lifespan it's equivalent to taking a
person and putting them in a room that
is barely bigger than they are for 80%
of the day and then letting them out
into a yard oh wait what does that sound
like actually in solitary confinement
well that's a story for a different day
in any case SeaWorld is getting a lot of
PR benefit from this but the reality is
they're saying okay we have 24 orcas
currently in three parks this will be
our last generation we're not going to
breed anymore they still have 40 to 50
years with the current whale so if
you're thinking SeaWorld is shutting
down tomorrow it's not they still are
going to continue with the current
whales and they've said and this is true
they've said releasing the current 24
orcas they have into the wild would not
be good for them and this is absolutely
true we know that when whales are born
and bred in captivity or even brought
into captivity after living in the wild
and live in captivity for a while they
can't really survive out in the wild
that is absolutely true but this entire
thing is an ending right now SeaWorld
doing everything they can for PR benefit
when they're gonna continue this
nonsense for 30 40 50 years and I
believe they also said that they are
going to phase out the shows the
theatrical shows by yeah 2019 and so I
guess that helps too well you're gonna
change the training that you do with
them because they're not going to be
doing theatrical shows but presume that
the understanding is you'll still be
able to go it'll be like a zoo like
atmosphere yeah and so what can we say
if they're not going to release them I
mean I guess that this is as good as
gets until their they are dead and yeah
and this isn't going to happen anymore
and for those who haven't seen blackfish
watch blackfish right and if there are
other organizations like SeaWorld
internationally or wherever that are
using orcas doing this type of stuff
boycott them when I was a kid I always
wanted to go to SeaWorld and my parents
never took me they did end up taking me
to Disney World once but not to SeaWorld
and I'm glad I've never been and I would
never go there and I would suggest to
everybody who's listening do not go
there if your kids want to go there
don't say listen I know it's bad but I'm
doing it for the kids
I think the much better lesson would be
explaining to the kids why it's really
really bad what's being done to the
animals there yes it's it may not be in
your budget to bring them somewhere
where they can observe killer whales in
the wild but you can have them watch TV
you can teach them about this and I
think that understanding is going to be
much more important for them and for the
world no doubt no doubt whatsoever all
right we have a fantastic membership
special going on you can get a
membership for thirty three percent off
and get a free david pakman show t-shirt
with that membership by going to david
pakman.com slash spring 16 and by
signing up every member in good standing
no matter when you signed up as of March
28th will be entered to win one of five
pairs of elite xt wireless bluetooth
headphones these are really cool we've
tried them in studio we will be giving
away five pairs to members in good
standing on march 28th in the meantime
get the free t-shirt and discount at
david pakman.com slash spring 16 fresh
books is offering david pakman show
listeners a 30 day free trial of their
service I'm obviously the host of the
David Pakman show but I also run the
business that is the David Pakman show
and I want to spend as much time as
possible on the show and growing and
improving my business so FreshBooks lets
you get paid more quickly it helps with
invoicing it helps with so many of those
business administration tools and it's
for freelancers and small businesses who
want to get organized on those issues
and really focus on growing the business
so to get your 30 day free trial of
fresh books and support the David Pakman
show go to go fresh books calm
/ TDPS that's go fresh books.com / TDPS